[Music]
yeah really
know how tinder works
she's not looking for hookups i just
know you swipe
in different directions oh she loves
traveling road trips
she loves travel traveling road trips
dogs and cats photography and
videography she loves
photography and videography and i don't
know why
she also loves dogs and she also loves
dogs
and she love a hug i don't know
[Music]
first date okay that's enough of me
singing jake thank you
we are going to introduce corridor live
as a concept starting with the podcast
once that gets green lit
then the podcast is going to be live on
youtube and on the website but
only website subscribers are going to be
able to comment in the video
oh cool and then obviously we can do a
little bit more of an interactive
element
where we can talk to people uh answer
questions
and not to have it just be a podcast we
can do like all different forms
of casting yeah um so i'm super excited
about that because we can still you know
it's
we can still take the time like we do
with this um
but it'll just be more there'll be more
options for us
like yeah whatever we're feeling that
day we could we could have the people
judge my tinder matches
yeah that would be we could swipe with
matt swiping with
yeah yeah so i think yes should i swipe
right or left
just an episode called swiping with matt
yeah and then we have to give you all of
your replies
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but only
based off the information of
just the first line of their their uh
bio description that's great yeah yeah
yeah well we know that she's an
outdoorsy gal yeah
so she likes dogs yeah she loves dogs
netflix i love netflix
great it's super easy you guys are so
you have
yeah i drink water like a couple times a
day
dude i mean we have a lot in common
though that's cool these guys don't even
know which direction to swipe
i don't know this whole case why are we
talking about this we we
started on this earlier this afternoon
because we were trying to
conceptualize like the totality of the
valentine's day render challenge video
that we have
upcoming so we were thinking like okay
who's the perfect candidate it's got to
be somebody single
somebody who's on tinder eliminates
everyone and it's
quite a few um and then we've noticed
like okay hey
uh we've got one candidate and jordan's
here with the beer
swipe right on that you accomplished
what the guillotine channel never did
[Laughter]
so the topic of today's podcast is how
do you find a story yes
oh yeah it sounds a little bit vague and
boring i'll be honest as a title but
well this is a great time for that
because yes we're literally talking
about how we found
exactly that's why i was going into it
yeah
eventually was gonna i was gonna yeah
but here's what here's why it's not
vague because if you can find a story in
anything
you can captivate people and once you
can captivate people with
anything you have the power of making
wonderful a wonderful youtube channel
yeah it's a it's a super power that
nick has developed for years matt you've
developed it as well for quite a while
you already had the superpower before
you joined us um
i don't necessarily have that superpower
oh hush
get out of here of course you do uh
jake's got it though if you ever see
one of your ad reads you would know that
jake has ability to make a good story
out of anything
i appreciate that like today's sponsor
brilliant.org
look at that segway i wasn't even
planning that and now's that time in the
podcast where i tell you about today's
sponsor brilliant brilliant is a new
sponsor
on the corridor cast so be nice okay and
listen up brilliant
is a math science and computer science
based learning website and app
now what does that mean they have
interactive learning tools which allow
you to fundamentally understand
concepts that shape our universe do you
remember when you were in high school
hey maybe you're in high school right
now but i remember when i was in high
school
and they said hey learn these formulas
well guess what i don't remember any of
them today
through this interactive learning you
develop a framework to understand
not only the formulas but then how to
apply them to novel problems when i was
scrolling through brilliant one course
that caught my eye was the introduction
to neural networks now not only did the
interactive courses allow me to
fundamentally understand
how these massive data sets are run
through these networks
but all of the courses that brilliant
has have interactive sections like this
you master concepts by solving fun
interactive problems
yourself rather than having somebody
tell you how to apply a formula
head on over to brilliant.org
corridorcast to get started for free
if you're one of the first 200 people to
sign up you will get 20
of your annual premium membership uh but
anyways
back to the podcast um but really like
the the art of telling a story is a
unique one and it's something like it
doesn't just apply like doing it in
videos you can do it in conversation
you can do it in a song it's like the
core things because once you kind of
pinpoint them it gives you this power to
captivate people
and that's kind of what we wanted to
talk about today's podcast
yeah it's also um a topic of nick's
functional filmmaking episode so i
wanted to give people
i guess just a little bit of like the
philosophy behind
uh what that episode is and then like
obviously how we apply it which
led us to today of talking about this
stupid valentine's day render video
um but more on that later more on that
later folks stay tuned
more on that more on that later
i am um once you swipe right
right it's when you swipe right right is
it wait you swipe left right no no you
swipe right
right when it's good you swipe right
when you swipe
but what's left after that then you you
swipe left
right wait which direction are you
swiping swiping left is the right
move if i swipe this way yeah same
direction that you
swipe this left swipe my left or your
left no you have to
mirror no you did you don't hear me you
don't mirror me you do the opposite
thing
so this so okay left swipe right swipe
right swipe is good yes
[Laughter]
you get you have to go out with them
that's that's the rule yeah is it is it
like
she loves me she loves me i wish i could
have that
yeah like a digital version of that oh
yeah the flower petal picker yeah
developer just got a great idea you know
i'm pretty sure
that all flowers are symmetrical with
their petal pattern
meaning that they would have even
numbered of course
so not necessarily not necessarily oh
yeah that's true there's five petaled
flowers out there yeah okay they make
them all shapes and sizes
pentagons are symmetrical and they have
odd numbers that's true um all right so
anyways
nick um just give us like nick take it
away
just give us like top level like you
know well let's
let's talk about the valentine's one as
an example yeah yeah how do you make a
story
and how do you make a story out of a
dating app like what what's
what i mean sometimes the stories just
fall into your your lap and sometimes
you have to
make a story or find a story rather
so for instance today we just tackled
this problem
in our meeting that we had an hour ago
yeah we're trying to figure out
what is the story we want to tell with
this like okay last year we did a
valentine's day render challenge
and that was really funny and there was
a real story we were all like hey we
have a couple days oops
none of us got valentine's day cards
let's just make one in this challenge so
that was a real thing
um but what we did today was more of
like okay
how can we change that how can we spin
it what tools do we have
yeah at our disposal here so and i
you know you also want to choose the
right story
you know which stories do you swipe
right on
how do you know which ones to swipe
right on well i mean
that's a good question and that's a
little bit of what i go into but
more more so what i go into in the
functional filmmaking episode is
how to have a swipe right story
be or how to have a swipe left story and
turn that into a swipe right story i
don't know
how to make any story into whenever how
to turn a swipe left into a bride
yeah but i mean it's meant to be a
universal like
dive into just like how we approach
making our videos
and again everyone's different and uh
you know
each one is special but there are some
universal
rules and uh and little maxims that we
have developed
over um god how many years many years of
making vlogs and stories and
crew videos now so even those
so just disclaimer even those universal
truths if you will are still
kind of subjective to what our filming
style is yeah but and it changes if you
had
let's i think we should go around like
if you had to point them out
like what would you say
three things you know like fundamental
okay it's gotta be it's gotta
i mean you need to have stakes that's
like the main thing i'm talking about
right that's
what we always focus on stakes what are
the steaks right like prime rib
or well yeah like exactly you gotta have
those juices
but a little bit i mean it's the primary
rib of storytelling um
you know today for instance talking
about this tinder
valentine's day video it was like okay
what are the steaks of you guys just
trying to make valentine's day cards
again
for your wives like we already married
them yeah
exactly my wife is gonna divorce me for
like making a baby yoda render no like
there aren't
very many real stakes so that means
that we'd have to manufacture some so
it's like
you want to minimize how much you have
to manufacture something right
so that was just like okay there aren't
any natural stakes being presented here
like so what are some steaks and then
we thought what if it's like what if
it's making someone a tinder profile
picture instead
because they're steaks yeah you know
everything out
and what if it's making what if it's
nico and sam making mad
pictures um yeah you know so i mean i
think
that's a freaking hilarious story like
my boss makes me my tinder
and especially because you guys are of a
generation
where you've never used tinder yeah and
that's weird to say even
but like it makes me feel old
but like there will be a lot of i think
comedy
inherently coming from that like yeah
matt having to teach you guys how to use
tinder so that you can make him
something that's crucial for him
[Laughter]
like so there's like inherent comedy
that you can just like
hone in on so we already know and like
we were starting to get into that in our
production meeting about this
and i just had to be like stop like just
let's just stop
until the cameras are rolling until
tomorrow we're just not going to talk
about this
and here we are but yeah
so that's kind of i mean first of all
it's the whole first part of
what that class is is
how do you choose the story you want to
tell because there's a lot of ways you
could go
there's a lot of different ways so how
do you choose a story you want to tell
stakes stakes you do your research
you weigh the stakes and you communicate
with your subject
and get them on board make sure it's a
story your subject wants to tell too
because there's nothing more
disheartening
more disheartening and exhausting than
trying to force your subject to follow a
story yeah
um it never turns out as good as if
they're on board and that's something
that they're motivated by
right so yeah if you're talking subjects
too i think another
like key fundamental thing is having
good characters in your stories yes
it's super important to have characters
that have like strong motivations
yeah definitely and we got a pretty
strong motivation in
this hopelessly single person who needs
to get a valentine before valentine's
yeah yeah it's like it's starting to
affect your work productivity
i'm thinking about it all the time i see
him
you get temporary shot where it's like
nico peeling around the corner
and then the punch zooming on matt's
screen and he's like working on his
he's working on photoshopping his face
look better in his profile you should
open
we should open this video with like uh
that one song it's like it's showing
everyone with their partners opening
valentine's day
yeah like nico's like looking at ivy's
picture and like matches sitting there
yeah photoshop all day
you know it's probably worth talking a
little bit about where like character
motivation comes from though
because it's a word you know you throw
on a lot when you're talking about
stories but like
what is character motivation and
interesting you know it comes from
objectives it comes from goals and that
all ties back in the stakes right
because a stake is what happens when
when you don't meet your objective
what happens when things go wrong so if
matt's motivation
is to have a valentine's date well it's
like what is the motivational matt's
goal is finding somebody you know and
that motivates him to then go and make a
tinder profile and try to solve this
problem
because if he doesn't solve the problem
then the stakes manifest themselves he's
going to
cry alone in the bathroom for a while i
don't know a steak without a goal
but you need to you also need to
establish the steaks is it is it pork
tenderloin
it's not a steak at all yeah it really
is never a steak
it's only a steak respective to the goal
though that's the thing
like jokingly true as much as we're
talking about that's a super important
thing to point out like
you you have a ch you have a goal
and then the stake is like how
how cl how much you're going to have to
overcome
to get to that goal um and what happens
if you don't yep
yeah uh so yeah the stake i mean the
stakes inform you as to like
how emotionally charged are you to
achieve your results how motivated are
you
because if the stakes are low i mean but
then again
it's actually not really true i take
that back stakes don't have to be big
because as we saw in the ai video a
candy bar works fine for
me yeah yeah for sure if you make a joke
out of it though yeah because our
extreme reactions made that into it it's
either a joke or it's like the
characters that are in your story
that matters to them yeah like the
stakes are really high for them
even though maybe sticks as an audience
member that you don't think the stakes
are high
you know from your perspective yeah
because you see the characters like
really caring about
you know their end goals that's really
what matters and that's where
the small amount of directing comes in
connecting yeah yeah
performance well yeah you need to
translate that
passion and that that need to succeed
and go into what the audience can see
so like ren is super passionate about
putting a nerf dart on a drone nerf gun
on and drive
yeah but how do we make the audience as
excited well it's not hard when it's
wren
but you know for other people who maybe
aren't as charismatic or good on camera
you can really have to squeeze it out of
them sometimes
so well you guys solve that problem
really well with the drone video because
imagine that video where gran goes i
want to put a nerf gun on a drone and he
proceeds to try to put a nerf gun on a
drone and he eventually succeeds in
putting a nerf gun on a drone and you
shoot some nerf darts at the end of the
video like
that's a boring video it might seem
interesting but the moment you're a
minute into the video like why am i
watching this
yeah it's because it's missing something
that video is one of my favorite videos
we've ever done so how did you fix
that how did you make it a good video so
we entered january we leaned in we
leaned in and this is another thing
that's covered but we leaned into the
real events that went down
and part of what's magical about
corridor
is that we have a group of characters
essentially that are all
in proximity to each other some so
sometimes magic just happens
and jan obviously i mean i think he felt
that there was a story here and like
obviously like
he's a huge nerf fan too so i think
there's an automatic well that's another
huge thing that i don't know if people
know is like jan
is perhaps more obsessed about nerf than
anyone i've ever met in my entire life
yeah um so so like those scenes where
he's like
taking his headphones off and looking up
over the computer like that thing will
never fly
yeah that's all real like that was the
jan doing that and then we're like and
then it's like oh okay there's our story
yes right yeah and then you lean into
that
yeah so then we lean into it with the
end battle which is by the way
really interesting from a i think just
like
perspective of this is the first actual
time we've seen a drone do combat with a
human that was really trying to take it
down
yeah and we're actually seeing the
superiority that a drone
there's been no other example of like
can a drone with a projectile on it beat
a human that really wants to [ __ ] it up
right yeah and that is like all we have
to do i mean
also the pi there was a piloting
obviously
oh it's all about it yeah it's all about
rounds deal with it but it is possible
you could
you could actually make a drone with a
weapon a feasible
battle implement yeah and so that's
crazy it's it's
demonstrating basically like with ren's
piloting skills it's just an extension
like a sword is an extension of the
wrist like it's just an extension of ren
in that sense you know it's just like
instead of his
effectual point being close to his body
it's just over there which is crazy
because dude i mean
imagine the implications of that right
yeah oh they're already working right
hard tangent guys here we go we'll come
back we'll come back but let's talk
about drones that have been weaponized
for just one quick second
as a filmmaker you come up with crazy
scenarios all the time
yeah like before 9 11 happened like
filmmakers came up with the idea
of planes flying into like a u.s capitol
you know it's like that's in i think a
tom clancy book if i'm not mistaken
um it's like these ideas already existed
they blew up the white house well that
was aliens
shooting with a green light slightly
different
a little different okay um but you know
the specifics of like how
because you have to you sit there and
you're like how is the bad guy going to
do his thing what's going to be
unique about it what's going to be
clever about it and you end up having to
like brainstorm
these things and in doing so you start
to realize like oh dang this is like
here's a way you could really [ __ ] some
people up
yeah and like one of those things is
drones and like you know we think about
putting
something that shoots projectiles on a
drone you don't have to do that drones
are cheap the drone itself is the weapon
you could easily weaponize a drone by
just putting an explosive on a drone and
flying the drone into something it
happens
and
it's pretty crazy like and it's weird
that we don't really like talk about it
much because i feel like
yeah you know the media and like there's
a lot of these things it's like it'd be
really easy to do this
if people thought about it more but we
just don't talk about it so it doesn't
happen
right and like weaponizing of drones is
one of those things that would be really
easy to do but
we just don't talk about it and like
that's we even like talked about like
should what if we made a video like you
know a sci-fi thing or a thriller thing
that was one of the things like that
happened in it
you're like oh we don't really want to
give people ideas
and like in you know delve too deep into
this but
yeah crazy no totally the you can i mean
if you're
if you're vile enough you can come up
with a way to hurt and hurt people in
all kinds of different ways
it's a deep dark rabbit hole that has no
end um
you don't need warehouses full of like
barrels of chemicals with like
death charges on them no you don't know
like that's the thing
people that's that's why i'm kind of
like
that's why the libertarian in me is like
you know it doesn't matter what you do
like people are people
because um the law will never stay ahead
of people
like you can legislate and make laws for
absolutely everything but what
ultimately what binds people
to live together peacefully is just
trust
and like you you trust that when you
drive down the road the person in the
opposite lane is not going to swerve
into your lane and kill you
yeah you know uh i trust that a lot less
here
but yeah but like that's that and that
happens
every single day in every every place
and time and manner in which people
interact
there's like there's just this common
sense um now you know we can
we can say oh well if you do that then
this will happen right and that helps
but like
at the end of the day it just comes down
to
that i mean most thankfully most people
aren't manila yeah
thankfully um so yeah but anyways
um drones be scary man but that's the
video so
you know i think the ingenious thing was
you you guys figuring out that there's a
story here
this there's a the story is not
necessarily about ren building the drone
the story is about
wren beating his friend in the contest
so now there's stakes right there's
emotional stakes i need to beat my
friend why
i don't remember why but i'll just
assume it's going to make her unhappy
you know he doesn't want to be one of
the actual there was actual
was it like jan wanted to take it down
with an axe well only made one of them
too
yeah yeah and so dan actually broke
he wanted to take it down yeah you want
to destroy it now the other thing to
point out here that you mentioned
earlier but i think we need to sync up
is
is the idea of taking what you
actually get from both your characters
and from your actual circumstances and
then only manufacturing
like what's absolutely necessary to take
it from point a to point b
yeah just like blue yeah like if you if
you went up to
who would be completely unenthusiastic
about drones
like i don't know um
jordan jordan maybe yeah like she
maybe she is maybe she isn't but like
you take some random person who doesn't
fly them doesn't
and you're like okay so here's what's
gonna happen right you're gonna fall
you're gonna christian would be like
what
or like yeah even me i'd be like oh cool
yeah
and then you take the antithesis person
the the anti-hero
jan and you're like okay you're gonna
try to take it out vic why am i
you can't force it no exactly and so
even though
even though we didn't even though it
wasn't like we were sitting around one
day
and jan and ren came to a head and they
just happened to yes
and just happened to do it and we
captured it on camera
there's still like those inherent
characteristics
of those people that we pitted against
each other
uh to get that story and so
i don't know maybe sometimes people are
disenfranchised disenfranchised or dis
dis like enchanted enchanted that's
that's what i'm looking for
disenchanted about like oh well you just
made it up but that's
yeah all of all of storytelling is like
taking something that's there and then
just going
what if it was like that yeah that's
like
exactly and that's like reality
documentary or it's
i don't know what genre we fall into
it's like half reality half
narrative it's like a video blog yeah
video blog kind of
it's like a video they have a name
yeah yeah um you should check out this
creator called casey
neistat yeah something like that but
he does some really good um
[Music]
yeah he lives in like chicago or
something but okay uh
really what it is is you want to meet
with your characters and
get on the same page about that story
from the get-go because then
you can set yourself up for capturing a
real story
and being on the same page for that
because like you know
using ren's video or this tinder video
like ren could have
we could have shot a million different
story beats
for that it could have been like yeah my
motor works you know or the shooterizer
finally works and that's like the main
clincher
like that could have been what we're
shooting for and it would still be just
as real of a video
yeah and probably with help of some
editing be
maybe as impactful but probably not as
much so
the fact that we decided this is all
going to be about this battle this duel
coming up
that the fact that we're all on the same
page about that through the week-long
process
means that i don't have to do much
directing because they already know
what we're shooting for they know the
story everyone's on the same page and we
can let those real moments play out
with as little meddling as possible
and like yeah like we'll get like
talking heads and like pick up shots
so like all that stuff but okay so what
so
what here i'm typing a comment yes nick
but what happens when the characters
don't do what you expected
uh well either you go with it and that
you just roll with it if it works or
i mean sometimes you'd have to put your
filmmaker hat on right
and get in and like you know direct them
yeah
and one of the most common like
questions you get as a director from an
actor is what's my intention
yeah with this line with the scene like
why am i doing this
and when you establish like a conflict
or a goal in real life
very often you don't get the questions
anymore yeah you can just follow and
film it and something's gonna happen
yeah i mean it kind of does eliminate
that question
um i mean there's not many times that
you know
i'm working with ren and he's asking me
why am i doing this
it's really me asking him why are you
doing this well i don't know how to like
explain this to the audience so it's
like that's the difference
because i wake up narrative directing is
90 exclaiming motivation
um but like you know that's just an
example of like
if you just find people who are
passionate and that's what you base your
content around
you're gonna have a good time and you're
gonna have good stories coming from that
because
you know again the best videos are the
ones that have true passion
igniting the ideas so like that's step
number one
is like make sure that whoever you're
filming or whatever you're filming
knows the intention of your story so
that's the first thing we talk about
in the functional filmmaking episode
yeah
uh the intention right yeah yeah and
like just figuring out
it's like the pre-production aspect of
the video so
and then you know we kind of take it
from there i mean the the episode
follows
me making the uh the avatar 2
uh video with sam and like we filmed
that video while we were i was actually
making that video so
you know he had a person filming it's
funny yeah
because carmichael dan jordan's filming
daniel
she's filming for instagram daniel's
filming for the vlog daniel's filming
carmichael who's filming me
yeah there's like a clip of this on
chris the human video centipede
literally a human video like this
feedback of media
capturing going on this feedback loop
never have we ever knocked out so many
different videos
so many different channels yeah that's
peak e efficiency
efficiency um but
yeah um do you remember back in the day
we had the uh
like our initial rule set when we're
approaching the vlogs
and like trying to figure out like
here's the rule for how we need to make
stories do you remember our rules
oh god i i'm sad to say i don't
not not rules so some of them already
never listened to the rules guidelines
uh more like guidelines so the first one
was
you know state what you're trying to do
what your goals are
and state what's at stake if you fail
you know
my goal is to make a drone that can
shoot a nerf dart and if i fail
jan is going to gloat
over me for the rest of his life that he
is better than me at nerf you know
whatever the stakes don't actually
matter as long as they're important to
the characters it can be a candy bar it
can be the end of the world
it only matters the character is
emotionally invested in it um
so truly you can make a story out of
anything but that's like the beginning
step
because then you need to establish uh
something go like what's in your way
what's going to prevent you from just
conflict yeah it's like so then i hit a
button and a drone came out and i was
done like you know
what's the challenge what's the problem
well it's hard to make a drone
the shooter riser doesn't work the
propellers are in balance the battery is
going to die too soon these are all
problems
that can prevent me from reaching my
goal and if i don't reach my goal the
stakes kick in
yeah so you establish the problems and
then
you also establish how you plan on
surmounting those problems how you're
going to overcome them and then you
watch as the character attempts to do
that
and that we applied to i mean we applied
it to anything like literally could be
i'm missing a file if i don't find the
file i'm not gonna get the video done in
time
so the challenge is i need to find it
but that's honestly a challenge that's
just your goal
the challenge would be but i only have
10 minutes to do so or
the search function doesn't work in
windows so to come up with a solution
i'm going to try this instead like once
you start doing that
then the story happens yeah uh otherwise
you don't have any middle to your story
you only have your beginning and end
it's all about those stakes man here's
what it was here's this
troutons it was goals
stakes challenges in that order
followed by the philosophy of show don't
tell
yep so i know you all heard show and
but guess what it's not show antel it's
show don't tell
because no one wants to hear you to say
tell them about something that you're
dead or going to do
they want to see that play out with
respect to the context that you just
gave them
when you give them the goals stakes and
the challenges and that's still
pretty much how we do the setups
and the payoffs of what we do now yeah
yeah always try to do that that's
definitely and for
narrative directing too always show if
you can always show yeah
or you know like or imply
normally most lines can be shown not set
yeah yeah um gosh i look like yeah
even some of the even some videos that
aren't that old
i like i was watching the pub g mobile
video and like i jump into the van with
you guys and it's like
man if we could reshoot that scene
just my lines are so drawn out i'm like
guys
thank you for saving me now let me give
you this
and let me give you this piece of
information and it's like it's those
pauses in between the lines i mean
information
those people don't know it but it's like
dumping a bunch of information i could
have said
all that in like two lines i think it's
a bit different when you're making
internet
tailored content i'm sure there's an
element of that like you need to really
like
be more people's faces with info maybe
and not like
but honestly i've been watching movies
through this lens for a while now and
it's like it's the same thing and movie
editing has changed you know to be fair
like now it's like way more to the point
but i think it's worth pointing out like
nowhere in this is the discussion of
and you need to show the emotion like
emotion
almost doesn't matter because the
characters are just a vessel for the
audience to put themselves in your shoes
that is so true and it's like the
biggest thing i've learned is like
actors don't really need to act they
just need to like
they just need to do simple tasks
and like you can break down those simple
tasks
so [ __ ] basically and like that's
where you'll get good acting
if they're thinking about the arc of the
whole movie and
it's like they're faxing a paper in the
scene which a lot of actors do they're
like
how does this tie in it's like no your
goal
your sub goal is to load the paper
in the in this bigger goal which is to
send the facts and the bigger goal which
is to
send the valentine's facts to your
girlfriend so she like
it's like but you're only thinking about
that one thing in this moment like don't
think about the weight of the world
right now
right because you won't you're not and
most of the time when you do something
it's like when i'm when i'm saying this
sentence right now i'm not thinking
about like oh okay well this is going to
be in a podcast and then that's going to
be part of this and then it's going to
be part of that
like no i'm just reacting to what you
were saying
and then saying giving you something
back um
yeah no that's good advice like actors
don't need to act yeah just
it's just less is more you need to react
really really yeah yeah
just do yeah yeah well the thing is if
you if you've laid out your story points
the audience is thinking about how would
they feel in that situation that's
kind of what you want you know so your
character ends up in a spot where
they're not going to achieve their goal
the stakes are going to come rushing
home
what's going to happen to them and then
you go boy if i was in that situation
i'd feel really nervous
that's what you want and then you want
to [ __ ] with the audience and not give
them what they would feel
yes yeah or you just you know you
you draw it out or you put a twist on it
or whatever but yeah yeah it's
you know acting is important but it's
almost like
being a puppet and i'm i'm sorry to all
the actors listening to this podcast but
it's almost more important to be a
puppet to convey information than it is
to like
be authentic and like give deep emotions
and that's not that's not true for every
story by any means but like
you know if you're going to be crying on
the scene it usually it's because your
character should be crying this
situation not because we want to see you
in pain
yeah you know it's just you're just
being a puppet it's you're just
this is what the character would be
feeling that's why ryan gosling i think
is a good actor
yeah because there's just enough not
going on
where the audience can put themselves
into those eyes that are just staring
off into the distance
yeah yeah like there's just enough of
that disconnect where it's like
okay i can actually like put myself in
that moment of just like
wonder he's got that clint eastwood
school of thought yeah
sure like him but like he's not
any actor is supported by the craft of
the film
in that like for example like this the
facts thing the fact scenario right
if you want him to be thinking about his
girlfriend while he's sending the facts
well what do you do i mean you don't
need you don't need to show the
performance necessarily you need to cut
to a shot of his girlfriend
or like what he's thinking about if
that's if that's the kind of story you
want to tell
it's like that hitchcock thing where
it's all about the um it's all about
little moments
it's all about those little moments yeah
yeah and how you cut them together and
how you tell your story
there's also that russian filmmaker that
did the psychology experiment where
me it wasn't a russian filmmaker
hitchcock was i think that's what you're
talking about it's like where you show
some
imagery and you show a person's blank
face yes yeah i believe it's a
psychology experiment actually
and the people would write down what
that person was feeling
and so it's the same picture of a
person's face every time but depending
on the image shown before people be like
oh that man
he's lost in sorrow he's he's trying to
hold back laughter
he's thinking about when he was a child
like they're applying all that just by
showing an image and showing the person
looking
yeah theoretically looking at it yeah
it's that emotion association where
that's just like
your inner thoughts are important for
you as an actor just to like you know
really get into your character but
really at the end of the day it's about
editing you know it's about like what
you put together and how you weave that
story
and story yeah yeah yeah it's like if
you as long as you give the audience
facts like
you know here is a car crash and
two people died boom here i'm playing it
out in front of you it's a movie boom
you watch a car crash
cut to a person watching it
don't they don't need to act all you
need to do is cut to the person watching
and me the audience goes
okay what is that person thinking what
are they feeling what's going on like
yeah that's all you have to do as a
filmmaker imagine this
okay there's like three images there's
like one image of children playing
there's one image of like
an impoverished person and then there's
one image of like
a wedding you know and and
in between those images you cut to an
emotionless image
of somebody else yeah as if they're
watching that
sure but they have the exact same
expression use the exact same footage
each time
if you go children playing emotionless
person
what do you think what's wrong with them
you know
uh impoverished person what an emotional
person
they lack empathy uh wedding
emotionless person are they not happy
about this
he's probably single
each one of them brings up three
different emotions that we
perceive onto that person just because
of the image that came before it
has nothing to do with their image so
think about that when you're
like consuming not just like
entertainment but think about that when
you're consuming information
about the world and what other people
are telling you about the world
like it's like what was the information
they gave me before this
what was the headline what was the that
was the image that came with it what was
like
because that's all if you think the news
media doesn't do that like
they're they're like the best at it yeah
you know
um so that it's just interesting how
like the same philosophies apply to like
entertainment and like you know stories
that we want to utilize
to like inspire people to you know
and not just enjoy our stories but like
do what we
hopefully we're inspiring people to like
do what they want to do in life
and then also how that can be used as a
tool to
manipulate too it's it's like yeah
that's why that's powerful the idea yeah
the idea of the empathy machine
being like film you know or just me
moving picture in general it still
applies
um it's just funny there's so much of it
now i don't know if we think about that
but
it's definitely yeah definitely watered
down yeah yeah like it's definitely just
there's there is so much over saturation
but yeah i mean all those principles
are somewhat applied to the stuff we do
yeah on the crew channel with the vlogs
and
you know experimental videos and stuff
still even more so now
now that we're more a little bit more
like it's a little bit less freeform
yeah in not in the actual like events of
what happens but like
now that there's so many more people
here and it's not just like six guys
sitting around in a studio
with carmichael filming you know
which was only like two or three years
ago a couple years ago
i mean you know people always say like
hey why don't you guys do all the vlogs
where you're just
you know following us around everyday
life in the studio and it's like
yeah there's so many reasons for that
but one is that
that that magic
is can't be recreated now because
the only reason we were able to do like
two stories cutting back and forth
together every other week
or every other day was because there was
literally like
just enough people like six people doing
their own thing
was just enough to like and it wasn't
too big to hinder that
right but it was enough for like one guy
carmichael and then eventually me once
we started growing
yeah to like cover all that stuff that
everything that was happening
like everyone had something going on at
all times and we'd that would feed
the machine you know of stories that we
were telling yeah
but it's a little bit different now i
feel in that like
once you start adding more gears to the
machine if you start pulling out a gear
it will derail everything so like we
just have to be more tactical about
which gears we pull how they intersect
yeah
and daniel like you might say well
daniel's making
blogs right but like you'll see
the stories he's telling are also more
put together than what we
like they're also it's a totally
different kind of video yeah
but i think that's well that's a mostly
from daniel's
artistic uh like vision
but also i think it's just like you have
to
be a little bit more tactical and a
little bit more
have that producer hat more when yeah
when you're filming around here these
days
and we used to i mean look as much as
the the old
original vlogs are as much as they have
a special place in my heart
like not a lot of those are that
entertaining
like you know yeah yeah i mean it's like
30 30 like some of those
got like 30 40 000 views because it's
just us like
[ __ ] around you know and it's like
yes
that's it that's when we started to be
like hey why aren't these getting views
you know why don't these have like more
interest and we're like oh it's probably
because in this one that has a hundred
thousand views there's like a goal
and it's like maybe we should add goals
oh yeah okay
yeah but that's how you do it like how
else would we have known there's no
school for this
yeah you can't just be like oh vlog
school yeah
no for sure i mean there's like you have
that
that uh idyllic like sense i think when
you watch the vlogs that like
the stuff's just always happening and
like yeah we captured that
and that was the reality of it and like
it's still a magical place i'm not
saying the magic's gone
i'm just saying like i feel like the
videos
i feel like the videos have gotten so
much better because we've been able to
just hone in on
all the good parts right and yeah i know
like
well i thought it was good when it was
just like slice of life
like fine but like same time
like you were saying looking back on
those videos it's like
if you wanted to boil down one of those
videos to someone
what what do you show them like like i
would constantly find myself being like
this video's dope i'm gonna show like my
friends my family and i'd like open the
video and then like half of it is
something they
don't give a crap about and it's like oh
i just get back to that and it's like
okay oh that's the sponsor segment
and then i show them this little chunk
and they're like what
but that's like that's everybody else
besides the croutons
you know so like i'm just yeah we get to
still like
keep those cool experiments and stories
and
like have people actually on a wider
scale care yeah
which is dope it's refining it yeah
refining it and refining it
and then when we when we do bring
something out into the ocean of
internet content we're like well
actually
look at the refined gold which we have
found for you
this nugget it is pure and honest
let it be yeah
so that's i think it's a positive change
yeah we've found we've found a good
thing and that's that's all from
focusing the story
right whereas like before you're kind of
i think it's focusing the story i mean
we've also as jake can speak to
we used to do a lot more like diy craft
stuff i think it's focusing in on the
niche
that we're like right we have to
pigeonhole ourselves a bit
thank you a little bit yeah if we would
take it away yeah if we would have gone
down the
path of like continuing the diy stuff
like
that really would have required me to
like build out an entire other arm
of the company not saying it can't
happen because you look at like
what's that dude in montana alex steele
or
is that a porn guy i don't know there's
a dude
no there's a dude out of montana who's
like a medal fabricator
and uh he's actually from the uk but he
wound up in montana and he's got this
whole workshop
and it's like every day he's like
working on
all kinds of insane diy stuff
and you know swords and like hammers and
like
you know because he does all the
medieval weapons yeah yeah i've seen
this
um and so i was inspired a lot by
a lot of what he was doing and i was
like man this would be
cool and this would be great and we we
were
coming up with like good story lines to
follow through on
on that and um you know i think the the
epitome of it was the chainsaw video
like we finally like yeah nailed it and
then the guillotine
yeah that was some of the best jake
build [ __ ] content but the thing about
those is that it's when
when you gotta go for you have the
elevator pitch
you know it's like look everyone knows
that youtube's a platform
hey what's your channel about exactly
exactly like
you you only have that amount of time to
capture someone's attention
and like yes once they've once their
attempt attention has been captured you
can tell a greater story
but still to get them there from start
to finish from like the 15 seconds that
you have to the 15 minutes that you have
you got to be
rule number one with entertaining people
is don't waste people's time
like you gotta you gotta do that and and
it's just
with the skill sets that you guys have
on the
on the post front like the actual
ability to
render and create things with computers
is like a completely different skill set
and obviously the rest of our content is
tailored to that so
like going down the road of doing heavy
diy stuff is is just
not it doesn't fit with the rest of the
narrative i mean that was just one of
the branches
like there's so many we had we had a
magic video which is an amazing video
don't get me wrong
that's amazing brian markinson shout out
but
i mean hey like check out this magic
video
on the channel and we built a chainsaw
yeah yeah
he does magic and that guy did effects
all right on to the next one guys see
you in a day and a half
tomorrow we're going to go to the ocean
and look at some fish
imagine oh and by the way before that
we're going to go to the park and play
uh arrow golf yes and i mean
there's yeah that's that was a an
amazing
uh thing to have because we just like
but
it was also like we were just mining for
for uh so imagine back to the whole game
of life thing another
random tangent in the channel which is
amazing but like we were just looking
for
what's our niche yeah because right now
imagine when you're listening to a band
like that
yeah like a different genre i really
love [ __ ] corridor crew
music and they're like what what's that
what's what
kind of music do they make and you're
like well they do a little bluegrass
and uh a little progressive rock and a
little edm
and a little lo-fi yeah they're like
what what so what songs that i listen to
and you're like that sounds like an
awesome band
i don't know it's cool
it's worth mentioning we don't like this
is something we've very much
acknowledged and worked into our
strategy but we're not necessarily going
we're only doing this one thing yeah
like we still have that variety we're
just a lot more
measured about when it reaches prime
time it gets put in front of
you know a million people on course it's
because dude like we've freaking
we've been raising our own ceiling and
now we got to build more stairs to get
there
seriously like there's a it's yeah
i know it'll shift eventually like the
winds of the winds of taste that's the
beautiful part
shift and as an artist you need to be
open and receptive to that you can't
just be like no offense harley but epic
meal time
like you can't just produce the same i
love those guys but like they've
produced the same video for the last 12
years
pretty much and it's like that's
it's easy to fall into that yeah i don't
i don't ever want to do that like no
offense
it works for them and it works for other
people but like i just at the end of it
i know the winds of change will come and
we'll have to
you know a shift in the wind foretells a
change in the weather
you know and we'll have to do something
else and like up our game in another way
and that but that that
that force of life causes you to be a
better
artist at the end of the day yeah
there's a there's a bit of a
i guess a philosophy behind things going
viral
um and you can phrase this in different
ways what really boils down to is
if someone with a unique perspective can
share that unique perspective that only
that person can have
on something that's a common experience
you will end up
with interest so this is this is a
different aspect of storytelling now
we're getting into like information
but you know it's kind of like the whole
you know professional
rock climber you know uh breaks down
wall climbing rock climbing scenes from
movies you know so only that one
like maybe another professional rock
climber could talk but like only
professional rock climbers could come in
and break down a rock climbing scene for
a movie and be like this is what they're
doing right this is what they're doing
wrong and you're interested because that
person's in
a professional um and this is something
like you know stunt men react like we
probably like we might be able to do an
episode or two of some men react without
a natural stunt man on the show but
beyond that like we have to have a
professional stunt man
because they are a very unique
individual with a very unique point of
view
that can talk about a common experience
which is say an adventurous movie
you know everybody seen an adventures
movie except for clint um
we'll work on that but not everybody can
sit down be like okay so here's how they
did that stunt in avengers
and you know i've seen that popping up
all over youtube you know a doctor
giving insight into
you know a unique medical case that only
a doctor can give an insight to or
you know i can go on forever you know an
artist giving inside and so on and so
forth but
why do you think people like those
videos well people like learning and
like
really at the end of the day you're only
really gonna learn something new
if the person talking to you and sharing
that information is somebody who's
an expert in the thing they're talking
about you know like
even on this podcast we see that happen
like our the one we talked about the
luke skywalker deep fake
uh that podcast outperformed all the
others and we have podcasts where we
just
shoot the breeze and talk about what
we're interested in but you know like
i'm not a professional video game
designer if we talked about video games
you know it might be fun
it might be fun to hang out and now you
have the context but you know it's not
going to go
viral no one's going to need to tune in
to see what niko has to say about you
know the last of us too like who cares
well okay so on that note if you go back
i don't know if
anyone's ever done this but if you go
back and watch old joe rogan podcasts
like the really early ones it's
literally like him
and his buddies just
just effing around yeah just effing
around saying that like
stuff that he could not say which they
probably quote him on all the time
yeah and then you you can see
over time he began to refine his process
same exact thing
like he he began to understand like oh
okay like when i
do this like people are more receptive
to it when i do that people aren't
when i have these types of people speak
about these types of things it's more
interesting to more people generally
like as a as a creator you're gonna
you're gonna recognize those things and
you're gonna track them and pay
attention to them because that's gonna
help
you inform hey people are responding to
this like if you didn't do that you'd be
a bad artist
you know yeah and so yeah i just like
i don't know it's it's interesting to
see how that i mean it's why we're doing
this podcast
how to make a story out of anything
featuring nick laurent
well it is yeah because we were talking
we were like hey we we
and we kind of knew this about the
podcast like obviously the ones where we
focus more on what the common niche of
the content
is across across all of our content like
they tend to
have people tend to tune into them more
yeah and so we just thought well let's
let's keep going in that direction
because that's what people want to hear
us
talk about um so well like we've seen
little clues too in the past like we
released a couple of videos where it was
like
we hadn't quite like made the full
mental connection
the vfx artists react like we did like
the why
do muzzle flashes and movies look weird
or like yeah you know
and that was like but like it didn't
quite like get that sparky guys
oh people seem to like when we explain
things and then it's like
we never did anything we're like how do
we do a video about explaining things
we never thought to just like do a video
explaining things and like
it just yeah i mean i don't know how it
took us so long to be honest but like
because it came out you don't just want
to sell out everything
potentially yeah like you don't you
don't just want to show up and go
oh my god that that could be that could
work
you know it wasn't just the potential
though it was like we were adding our
voice to the sonic meme
you know which was a relevant thing so
it was like
that was just like we felt the call yeah
and
it just it was a natural thing which i
think
speaks to it things i think in a world
where vfx
react didn't happen you know
you know we wouldn't have those who we'd
still have the same i feel like the same
midweek videos are called i mean they
come out on sundays now
we still have the same other set of
videos i think that we're in now i feel
like the same refining process would
have happened we'd still be doing the
satisfying renders the luke skywalker
deep fakes like
because that's that's the path we were
already on you know
before we started vfx artists react um i
just wonder like
how that would i think we would still be
kind of
a mixed bag channel which i don't think
would have
taken us on the same trajectory i i
agree because like
that was hurting us even though it's
like some of my favorite videos or the
random like crafting videos or something
like on youtube i think that consistency
is key like when you order a national
geographic magazine you don't want to
get
dude i have a magazine
i have a small like tear
out of my eyes dude i know well no the
thing is it's not
all positive because now those videos we
don't get to make and like
you know like we were talking about we
had this knife video that we started
shooting
like will it ever get done i think it
will do i think we can't knife video is
never getting done
like dude honestly the whole like the
whole thing could be different yeah
and it could be like well guess what i
am gonna make this knife video because
now this is interesting but obviously
the story that we tell isn't going to be
exactly the same
it all comes down to any difference i
think if the story is there we can still
have those videos on the channel well
that was my main thing
is like when we shifted to to more
vfx and filmmaking content my main thing
was like look
the reason why we we call it corridor
crew
is because if it's related to what the
crew is working on
then it's relevant to the channel which
was the thing that we lacked with chord
or digital
like it just it was all about
singular perfect experience which is
cool
but like we also had to attach it to
some
other form of relevancy that wasn't us
and so as creators you don't necessarily
especially on youtube you don't want to
put yourself in a
position where your entire dependency is
to make it relevant to something else
not to the things that like inspire you
yeah right so
that's the main thing if we can keep
that i feel like it's always relevant
because it's it's the things that we're
passionate about and things that we're
creating now it just so happens
as we've spun up more and more content
that's related to
expanding the realm of visual effects
and filmmaking
obviously we're going to attract more
and more people who are into that
not only just personally and within the
company but then also the viewership so
obviously
now that fortunately the realm of
computer frontier
is vast and is this is booming it's
booming
so there it's not like we're at the
other side of like a
you know something um so well i think
that was a discovery for us that we made
too we didn't
know that people wanted to see how
visual effects are made because
we actually thought the opposite to be
honest our philosophy which you were
very stringent on was no tutorials
yeah like me and carmichael would want
to like slip in a little tutorial here
and there like
hey what if we just like did a little
and you're like no they don't do well
which is true
unless you're like andrew kramer
tutorials
that's a whole different type of content
for sure but like tutorials don't pay
so we kind of wrote off the fact that
people wanted to learn about vfx yeah
to defend myself just a little bit
[Music]
forever
that's a headline for you right there
that'll that'll give you so
i do i do want to be specific so it
wasn't it was definitely no tutorials
but it wasn't
no teaching it was don't sit down with
the program and start telling people
what buttons to click
sure because that's that's not
interesting that's not a story like
teach me stuff like you know teach me
what makes a good muzzle flash teach me
what makes good cgi
but don't do a tutorial on it you know
so
you know teaching can be fun learning
can be fun it can be you know i love
teaching i love sharing my knowledge but
like you know learning is also great
it's super fun
getting entertained and educated at the
same time edutained
is great but you know we're not making
textbooks for people right you know
yeah so that was a discovery for us like
oh like we can make this fun and
educational yeah
and entertaining yeah and it also still
kind of follows the guidelines that you
set up where it's like the stuff still
is not
like we're not just sitting down at a
computer just telling people literally
word for word how to do it
it's more like the basic the core
fundamental principles of
10 hour live stream of how we made the
up video
which by the way uh on sunday
or probably on sunday no on sunday on
sunday
we're releasing um the scale of up
effectively which is how many balloons
would it take to lift the house from up
i mean i know other people have done
this but you haven't seen it like this
yes uh you haven't seen it this isn't it
this is ren's opus right here
it is um he would be in this podcast if
not for the fact that
he's he's cranking on it right now yeah
trying to get it done he was supposed to
sit right here
yeah that was gonna be right but i think
we made
another good one based upon dude i'm
excited
the idea of telling a story that's right
out of anything so i hope you guys
enjoyed this podcast
[Music]
no take it away uh hey if you guys want
to see what 30 million balloons looks
like floating through a city
check out this sunday's video how many
balloons would it take to lift the house
in a little millennial whoop coming on
[Music]
also my name is matt if you want to find
me on tinder please match with me
[Laughter]
i was wondering if i should hold that
four thousand
[Music]
then they came along
and said it's not gonna be long
before this whole thing goes
crushing on down
[Applause]
[Music]
so i got my shares and i brought them
to the market
[Music]
and they said son it ain't worth what it
was you we don't like it
and now i'm sitting on 25 shares
as a game star
i don't know what to do
[Music]
man this song is pretty good it's sad
man
thanks for listening everybody consider
subscribing if not
thank you so much